I'll save you I'm excited about big hero
sex and not just because I desperately
want to believe that a hairless doughy
white blob can become a mighty superhero
I explained why on this week's episode
of angry nerd first the mailbag Robbie
nitrites I love you angry nerd I wish I
could find you on Twitter
thank your lucky stars Robbie then go
follow angry nerd wired as soon as I
launched into the Twitterverse I was
having intense tweet chats about the
recent movie Dracula untold I keep that
with Kyle Waterford about how cool it
would be if the sequel was set in the
sci-fi future I discussed Romanian
folklore with a video and I heartily
seconded we'll Fulton's complained that
the impalement method in the movie was
not historically accurate Dracula is
Vlad the Impaler how can you get that
wrong anyway what was I talking about oh
oh yeah yeah okay the latest animated
feature from Disney is based on big hero
6 a Marvel comic that was spun off from
Alpha Flight C alpha fighter like the
Canadian x-men hey big hero 6 are like
the x-men of Japan think superhero
mutants within - of kaiju and dollop of
mecha and a soup's on of samurai but
I'll admit I had my doubts when I heard
that the man who directed the CG winnie
the pooh feature was the one who would
be turning this Marvel IP into a Disney
tool I can see you're going to be rather
feisty today
and I hoped out a tad when I learned
that they eliminated Sunfire and silver
samurai from the lineup of big hero 6
the two characters that were most hooked
into the rest of the Marvel verse and
they made all the other heroes and
heroines much younger it seemed like the
culmination of everything we feared
would happen in 2009 when Disney
swallowed up marble like Galactus
devouring a hapless planet Oh take that
Disney 2
pooh-pooh stop trying to turn marvel's
trademark adolescent onst into your own
signature brand of pre-pubescent
peevishness and i hope you learn your
lesson bonehead but since then I've
achieved it light and my gamma-ray rage
has subsided
you see I realized that this new movie
is not trying to be a kid-friendly
addition to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe this is just Disney adapting a
classic story like they did with Grimm's
fairy tales or Peter Pan I mean look at
Disney's adaptation of the 1880s
children's book Pinocchio
it maintained the skeletal outline of
the original story and just enough of
the ethnic origins to be vaguely
offensive it Sony Geppetto but the movie
refashioned the tale completely adding
different storylines that made it more
marketable and family-friendly if the
book Pinocchio kills the talking cricket
seriously what dis he did to the
Pinocchio book kind of mirrors what
they're doing to big hero 6 see at this
point giant robots and teenage
superheroes are timeless archetypes
modern-day folktales and Disney is
drawing on them the way their best films
have always done the trailers also make
a pretty strong case for the movie the
interaction between the human
protagonist hero and the powerful but
clueless baymax seems rife with
possibility a little bit like Iron Giant
a little bit like How to Train Your
Dragon but on the other hand the best
Marvel animated shows of the last
several years have been collaborations
between Western writers and Japanese
animation houses and the hands-down most
exciting thing in the Marvel verse this
days is the japan-only show Avengers dis
Wars a collaboration with Bondi that's
sort of like superhero Pokemon
I choose a wire man Pikachu I don't need
to see anymore I'm sold why is this disk
war show not available in America Marvel
this should be your top priority delay
the release of big hero 6 if you have to
put age of Ultron on hold and make Joss
Whedon supervise the English dub of disk
Wars pronto frozen characters are now
showing up on ABC's glorified Disney
fanfic series once upon a time I insist
the Disney characters baymax and
wreck-it Ralph be added to the series -
would you like to see that let me know
in the comments by the way
in a recent rant I just mentioned in
passing that I like Teen Titans go many
of you went absolutely ballistic in the
comments I get it I get it I get it
you hate Teen Titans go like Indiana
Jones hates snakes well I think it's
funny it's not a sacrilege it's a clever
twist on the formula however I hate the
cartoony new Disney XD version of
spider-man which adds funny asides and
shibi spider-man gets Spidey sensing a
connection though that it's a sacrilege
let me know what you think of Marvel on
Disney XD in the comments